as the dry ice went down your esophagus
you'd feel a little tingling there and
then it would travel down to your
stomach
as it's in your stomach the dry ice
would heat up and form gaseous carbon
dioxide
this is because as dry ice heats up it
doesn't become a liquid but rather a gas
hence the name dry ice
and with this gas in your stomach you'd
start to feel bloated and then a sharp
pain
and don't forget about the frostbite on
your stomach lining
luckily you could burp some of this gas
out of you
relieving some of the pressure you'd be
feeling but if you continued to eat dry
ice the pressure from the gas would
continue to build your stomach would
expand and get harder as the pressure
continued your stomach would rupture